um let's let's start so we're at the
intermediate level what i was gonna say
before i was rudely interrupted is that
i remind people that the premise of this
third speedrun is
essentially
playing as basic as possible i want to
do something that a lot of people on
youtube have requested
which is and i've done this a couple of
times before where we blunder
where we blunder um a piece in the
opening and then i spend the rest of the
game trying to come back
so i i used to i did that at a beginner
level i did that against 600 700 but
let's do that against a 14 1500 rated
player i can't guarantee that i'm going
to win
but i feel like a lot of people on
youtube requested games where i try to
come back against intermediate players
and so
and so uh that's what we're going to do
okay
let's go
[Music]
13 27 meet saul's
so we're going to go e4 and then we're
going to throw in the bishop to a6
and pretend that it's a mouse slip
thanks jtd and b takes a6 already a bit
of an encouraging sign i think black
should have taken with the knight
um now
the first the first step
for us is to develop i mean without
development we're not going to get
anything done
uh and
he says he says really without
development we're not going to get
anything done and so we should start by
playing pretty normally knight f3 we
don't i think a lot of people in this
situation would be tempted by f4
uh but playing the king's gambit down a
piece is just an immediate death
sentence
now i think the approach that we should
be taking here is to open up like we
shouldn't try to close everything down
that's not a particularly effective
strategy we should still try to open up
the center
and we should but we should do so in a
way that
attempts to
prevent uh too many pieces from getting
traded so what am i hinting at here i'm
hinting at the move d4 just like in the
regular philidor let's play the move d4
and we can still try to exploit our lead
in development
he wants to offer me a draw
yeah he's offering me a draw because he
thinks it was a mouse slip
this is really funny
i mean i guess like i suppose i could
accept and then try it again in a
different game
i guess i'll take the draw
that's a very very honorable thing to do
he says no i insist
that's incredibly old some of him just
shows you that uh
very wholesome of my opponent
uh that is a that is a very wholesome
thing to do
well thank you uh i appreciate it
he insisted on giving me the draw
i suppose we'll try it again all right
let's try it again
i mean this time
we're playing surge
from mozambique let's do this exact same
thing again
yeah i i actually orchestrated this
wholesomeness so
more subs for sure what do i do now
i mean you know
that's a very dangerous question to ask
me
i feel like this move is just so
it's so unusual that people are just
like what are you doing
i feel like he's gonna say something too
make it rain
this is a sacrifice it's a positional
sacrifice we're either ruining his pawn
structure or we are
getting his knight away from
the center
so it's uh
totally sensible
totally sensible idea
yeah that is a cool flag
mozambique
is there a name for it i think we should
christen at the nerdsy gambit
i think we should christen at the
narrative again but
oh yeah i don't think there will be any
uh any argument about that
okay so he takes on a6 with a knight
and um
again
nothing that we can do other than to
develop so we begin by playing knight f3
this is going to be very hard to come
back from because we did give away our
light squared bishop that's that's the
bishop which often allows us to attack
the king side of course
so it is going to be hard to generate
attacking chances and so we're going to
have to do the step by step
uh
trying to keep as many pieces on the
board trying to create complications
ultimately
you know when you're in a bad situation
when you're losing
um or you're down pieces the the thing
that you have to aim for first and
foremost is to create difficulties to
create a situation where your opponent
might actually make a mistake
all right
so knight back to b8 that's an
interesting move i i think that our
opponent is going for c6
uh and
knight takes e5 here is tempting but i
think it's going to be met with queen e7
and we certainly yeah we don't want to
do that we don't want to take on e5 and
allow queen e7 because then
once we move the knight back the queen
takes on e4 and we have to move our king
that's out of the question
we could play d4 here
but then i think
you would take on on d4 and then go
knight c6 and that also doesn't really
inspire confidence
so i suppose we can start by castling
and then we'll decide what to do on the
next move
i suppose we could start by castling
yeah so
probably the best thing to do for us
would be to play something like the
ponciani a move like c3
which perhaps will have the effect of
throwing our opponent off
i think that i think the move c3 makes
sense here uh because we've already
castled and if we can get a quick d4 in
at least we'll try to control the center
uh and maybe that'll be a jumping off
point for
uh for some momentum that we can build
up
yeah it's definitely worth a bishop the
two extra tempe so let's try c3
i'm not claiming that this is the best
move there's nothing particularly good
in this position
but it's a try
now knight f6 is what i like to see what
should we do now do we have to defend
the e4 punch should we go rookie one
you want to slap that move
no we should definitely not go rookie
one we shouldn't go d3 that's not in the
spirit of the position
we should go d4
and if you know any ponciani theory then
you'll know that this is the move the
point is that if e takes d4
then we push the e pawn to e5 this is a
common idea it happens in many different
types of openings scotch gambit
um being
probably the most common example
and if if knight takes e4 here well
that's not dangerous at all we can we
can either take on e5 or we can play d5
okay bishop d6 already
i mean that that doesn't quite give the
piece back up but it comes very close
and this gives us a big chance for
counter play
so what's wrong with this move on a
basic level well it blocks in the bishop
on c8
this gives us a significant lead in
development
so what tactical idea do i have my eyes
on
yeah so what we want to do here is we
want to push this f pawn out to f4
obviously not immediately because that's
illegal so what we can do
is trade on e5 twice
that bishop's going to land on e5 then
we go f4
our opponent is forced to retreat to d6
and we go e5 now i said that that
doesn't win a piece who can tell me why
what's the flaw of that idea what does
black do in that final position
unfortunately
unfortunately he's got the check he's
got bishop c5 check
and after king h1 the knight can jump
into e4
that position still looks a little bit
iffy for black
so we could go for it and then try to
find something there
but the alternative here is to keep the
tension with a move like bishop g5
the alternative is to keep the tension
in the move like bishop g5 i feel like
if we go for the first line i feel like
if we take it's going to force our
opponent into finding all the correct
moves
aha but wait a second
it goes there in the end
five tanks
no actually i have an idea there
i have an idea there let's go for d
takes e5
let's go for this line i came up with
what i think is a way to test black in
that end position
so let's see first of all if black even
goes for this i guess that
black could take on e5 with a bishop
but that would be a pretty bad move
ooh he's disconnected
oh no our phone is discus you see this
is like this is
how well these sacrifices work
i guess it's just not meant to be
too scared of the game but
way too scared of the gambit
way too scared of the game but now
there's a two-minute auto disconnect
because this is a longer game so
hopefully he'll reconnect with in time
you absolutely should
sub leader and smack leader
yeah this is a speedrun slash internet
slash i don't know what to call it
yeah basically our opponent finding our
stream would be would basically be like
kit boga who i really like to watch
sometimes uh when when one of the the
scammers recognizes him or finds the
twitch stream
that's always a scary moment when i was
on kipp boga
he was recognized
by by someone
which was pretty scary and then he was
trying to get that person to play chess
with him
and yes i did do a collab with kit boga
that is my one
uh ticket to non-chess twitch
fun fact
uh i think it's on youtube it might be
on in the vods i should have saved it
okay 25 seconds from disconnection it
looks like he's permanently disconnected
unfortunately
uh there's supposed to be a little bit
of snow tonight but not not much of it
yeah
well that said i guess i can show what i
wanted to do
in the event of of that line
that is
yeah i guess speed run is just not meant
to happen
we are meant to sit and wait for subs to
come in
so
a knight beat is a bit weird but
actually quite sensible
castles knight c63
knight f64 now in the main line ponciani
in the mainline ponciani c3 knight f6 is
the main line
d4
and now if e takes d4 you go e5 this
leads to tremendous complications this
is my game against bruzan from the u.s
championship
uh and this is probably black's most
reliable defense against the ponciani
knight d5
and this very much resembles an allopin
with the sort of the the whole thing
shifted because black now has the c bond
rather than the e pawn
um
but the move here is bishop c4 kind of
smith mora style knight b6 bishop b3 and
this leads to interesting complications
the position is objectively equal
so you can take a look at my my game
against brazant to see how black should
handle this this position
eric rosen recommends i believe the move
queen b3 in this position also very
interesting
so
i do recommend the ponciani as
as an interesting defense well i
wouldn't even call it i mean as an
interesting opening
uh if you want kind of a sideline
alternative to the rue lopez or the
italian but you don't want to play
something as insane as let's say the
king's gambit
no i don't prefer d5 i mean black's
other main line is d5 in this position
and here white has this weird looking
move queen a4
creating a pin against the bishop no i i
do prefer d5 i just prefer this gambit
line of bishop d7
because the vast majority of people play
f6 in this position and here i think
white's just doing well
but i i had the ponciani from the black
side and i i now remember that i showed
you guys this gambit with bishop d7 and
the knight d4 you can find that speedo
game on youtube
all right so bishop a6 takes here here
here c3 knight f64 how should black play
in this position
um yeah knight takes e4 is possible but
black can simply go d6
because specifically here because black
is a piece up
normally i would consider taking on e5
and then taking the queen right because
well if knight takes d8 then knight
takes e5 but because he's a piece up uh
this is out of the question for white
and so i think d6 would be the most
solid
okay so
if bishop takes e5 who can explain to me
why
this is already
quite good for white what does white do
here
thank you planet link
yeah well basically and i've talked
about this scenario many times when
there when there are knights
specifically on e5 and f6
that's a very dangerous situation and
there are no pawn there's no pawn on d6
like in your mind you should always keep
that keep that in your head because it
occurs in actually quite a few positions
uh let me think of an example of a
different example where this kind of
thing might happen
well this this there's a famous strap in
the alakyne where this happens so in
this position if black does not play d6
there's an old move knight c6
which loses the game on the spot white
plays c4 knight b6 and does the same
thing on the other side d5
looks like a blunder but no you go c5
the knight has only one square and now
you attack the other knight with f4
there's a there's a reuben fine game
that went this way black loses the piece
so knights are just very very bad at
at
finding safe spots
uh when they're being assaulted by pawns
so the same thing happens
in the event of f4
yeah so in this position f4 knight c6 e5
and this knight has to go back to g8 now
we can go queen g4 and white develops
quite a serious initiative
black is of course still better but this
is already something
um
so after knight takes c5 takes takes f4
bishop d6
e5 now there's this very important check
then the knight has this e4 square
who can tell me
what white should do in this position
what is the idea that i came up with
which at least
poses some problems for black
uh knock queen well actually queen d5 is
interesting queen d5 is very interesting
because after knight f2 check you can go
king g1 and the point is that the knight
doesn't have too many good squares
but i still think that black should be
good here
and if bishop b6 then of course you play
rook takes f2 and you win back some of
the material
no this is a very interesting idea i
didn't even have this in mind what i had
in mind was queen e2
now it's the same concept knight f2
check there will be rook takes up to and
if the knight is defended by d5 or by f5
then you take on passant in both cases
creating the pin
black is still winning in this position
because he can go f5
the knight is secure
but now i calculated further and came up
with the move knight d2 and if black is
not careful it's very easy to lose the
piece
for instance if black castles
that would be a serious blunder who can
tell me why
yeah and encode dinoco is already on the
ball knight takes c4 fe4 and queen c4
loose pieces drop off you win back the
bishop
so in this position black should
probably play c takes d6 to anchor the
bishop
but you know 94 queen e4 we've won a
pawn back but after queen e7 black is
still winning and he's going to castle
on the next move
and our initiative evaporates but that's
the best that we could have done
[Music]